By far the best way to build
a sender application for
Android is to use the cast companion
library, or CCL for short.
CCL provides a collection of ready to
use components that provide features and
behaviors recommended
by the US guidelines.
CCL primarily helps you build media
centric apps, but it's also helpful for
data centric use cases as well.
In this lesson, we'll take a look at
the major features and in the next,
we'll see how it's used in practice.
Now as you can see,
CCL does quite a bit for you.
The main features include a ready
to go mini-controller and
a full screen player.
Also included are notifications
to provide player controls when
your app is closed or out of focus.
Lock screen controls, so
the user can maintain control
even if their phone is locked.
Closed caption support and
WiFi reconnection support in
case the connection drops.
You control the CCL through
the VideoCastManager.
This is a singleton and maintains
the state of the application, and
keeps track of the connectivity to
the cast device behind the scenes.
It also keeps track of the playback
status of the receiver for instance,
if it's playing or paused.
Now for data centric app you'd use
its analogue which is actually called
the data cast manager instead
of the video cast manager.
Before you can use it you have to
initialize it as we're doing here.
When you initialize it, you choose
which features you want enabled.
The first argument is your
application context and
the second is the application
ID of your receiver.
We'll get the third and
fourth arguments later.
At this time you also select the types
of features you'd like enabled,
here we're enabling quite a bit,
notifications, lock screen and so forth.
When you use the CCL you want to create
an instance of the video cast manager
early, typically inside your
oncreate method of your activity.
Before you do so though it's
a good idea to call this method
to check whether Google Play Services
is installed and updated.
If it's not, the CCL will automatically
show the user dialog that will
direct them to take
the appropriate action.
The third argument when we
initialize the CCL is for
a player control activity.
If you leave it null,
CCL will provide one for you.
This player shows automatically
during media playback, and
provides controls to play,
pause, and seek.
You can also start this
activity manually if you like,
using the cast manager instance,
like this.
This argument by the way is
an instance of media info and
that's the class used by cast to keep
track of metadata for a video or song.
Check out a link to that
in the instructor notes.
Now the fourth argument is a name
space of a custom message channel
if you'd like one created between
your sender and your receiver.
Once the channel is created you
can easily send messages with just
a single message call.
CCL also provides call back to inform
you whether a message was received and
whether there was an error.
And, if you have a data centric app,
the DataCastManager makes it easy for
you to add a number of channels,
each with their own name space.
One of the ready to use components
CCL provides is the mini-controller.
This is a small controller that can
be added to the layout XML of your
different activities.
It's purpose is to allow the user to
browse to different pages of your app
while still being able
to control the cast.
If you use this component,
in addition to the XML, you'll need to
register it with the Video Cast Manager
inside your activities oncreate method.
Also remember to
unregister in ondestroy.
Behind the scenes, the Cast Manager
handles everything else including
updating its metadata, its playback
state, as well as hiding it when no
media is playing and for details on all
of this, check out the instructor notes.
Another great ready to go
component is notifications.
CCL shows these automatically when your
app is in the background or killed.
All you have to do is indicate you
want this feature when you initialize
the video cast manager.
Then, you need to keep CCL informed
when your app is active or not, and
you do this by incrementing or
decrementing the UI counter inside
your onStart and onStop method.
Another excellent ready to go
feature are lock screen controls.
When you enable this feature when you
initialize the video cast manager,
a play pause button will automatically
go on Android devices running
Jellybean or higher.
And as a added bonus, CCL
automatically provides the ability for
users to control the cast
device's system volume,
even if your application
is in the background and
you're screen is locked by using
the hardware controls on your phone.
CCL makes reconnecting to
a running cast sessions easy, for
instance if the WiFi drops.
To do so, it starts up a reconnection
service behind the scenes, and you have
to indicate you want this functionality
both when you initialize the video Cast
manager, and also by adding these
lines to your Android manifest.
You need these permissions as well.
Then, inside your on-create method,
indicate that you want to reconnect
to an existing session if possible.
In this parameter here is
a time out in seconds.
In addition to helping you
out of the wi-fi drops,
the reconnection services is also great
if your app is killed before you can
gracefully exit the cache section.
If the user then restarts your app,
you can automatically rejoin
the existing session.
That's the CCL in a nutshell,
we have an extensive PDF guide you can
find in the structure notes that will
provide details on how to use all
of these features in your app.
And again, if you're building or
extending an Android app to work with
Cast the CCL is definitely
your best way to go.
Another great resource is
the Cast video sample.
This contains a handy guide on
downloading and installing the CCL and
connecting it to another
project inside Android Studio.